i posted this morning the jets should
fire greg williams defensive coordinator
immediately
and they did
abracadabra only has one bullet though
unfortunately i've tried it's not my day
it was just for that fine sliver of time
and i don't want to make light of the
guy getting fired but you know what
shereen this is a big boy league he
deserved it for what he did yesterday
without question he deserved to be gone
today
i'm just questioning if it was immediate
was that immediate a few hours later
it wasn't it was within it was within 90
minutes it was within 90 minutes okay
all right so they had to make the
decision
they had to they had to see what i
posted
and and they all read pft i mean this is
one area where i am being serious if we
had the saturation level among the fan
base that we had
among the teams and the coaches and the
agents and the players and everyone else
connected to the game i could retire
frankly and then we wouldn't have the
saturation unless whoever takes over for
me is able to get that saturation but
they all read it and i suspect that that
the decision may have already been made
but i'm sure they they saw it there in
new york and we were just reflecting the
sense that was out there people were
saying this guy has to go what are you
doing you don't call an all-out blitz
with the game online anybody's ever
played any football watched any football
played any madden knows that in that
situation
13 seconds left the offense has no
timeouts they're on your 46 yard line
you defend the end zone you defend the
goal line you don't send eight guys to
prove some stupid point and take one
last shot at the quarterback and let an
undrafted rookie corner cover a
first-round receiver who ran a 4-2-8 i
gave lamar jackson the cornerback not
the quarterback a hard time yesterday
for biting on the double move
look he had to bite on the double move
because he had no one behind him if they
hit henry ruggs with a quick pass
he's gone potentially because there's no
one back there to tackle him so lamar
jackson was left on an island and it's
definitely not lamar island like it was
rivas island and that was that for the
jets and that's that for greg williams
and he got what he deserved and the
other thing too is i think it shattered
the confidence in greg williams
internally to the point where if they
want to win a game the rest of the way
shireen they had to move on from it
yeah no question mike and and they
should have made the decision right
after the game i mean this is one you
don't need to think about i know sims
called it dom and dummer i will call it
dumbest because it is absolutely in my
almost 30 years occur in this league the
dumbest play call i have ever seen and i
was trying to think of some that were
dumber and the only one that came to
mind right away was the barry switzer
one on fourth down and the eagles called
a timeout after stopping the cowboys on
the emmett smith run and he runs the
exact same play again after the timeout
and they're stopped again and that was
dumb and dumber at the time but this was
dumbest mike i've never seen
a
dumber you have the game one like i i
that's the only way you lose a game
there's one way you lose the game and it
made me question did greg williams want
out but if he wanted out you know what
he's not only out of the jets he never
gets another coaching opportunity after
that play call i guarantee you and it's
about time frankly for what he's done in
the nfl which is next to nothing and how
he keeps getting coaching jobs i don't
know but he does continue to keep co get
coaching jobs even after what happened
in new orleans in his career frankly
should have been over after that
i never thought he'd be back after that
primarily and fundamentally because he
committed what i thought was the
unforgivable sin of dropping the dime on
one of his players he submitted a
written affidavit saying that jonathan
velma did indeed offer ten thousand
dollars to anyone that knocked brett
favre out of the 2009 nfc championship
game once word of that emerged i thought
they would never accept him in the
locker room again and then i thought
this guy must be one of the great
defensive
tacticians of all time to keep getting
hired and hired and hired and hired well
he's not and he's gone and it's done and
it's over and maybe it was deliberate to
sabotage adam gase maybe he did want out
maybe he wanted to go out in blade of
glor uh blaze of glory maybe it was just
his ego taking over whatever it was
sharing the most
close comparison i came up with is this
is a defensive version of the miracle in
the meadowlands with joe pisarcic and
larry zonka with the fumbled handoff and
herm edward scoops it up and scores
not that you know that revolutionized
offense in that situation and introduced
the victory formation which everyone
uses now taking a knee instead of
handing off as you're trying to bleed
the clock and you know that the other
side can't stop the clock and you can
just get out of there with two or three
kneel downs
everybody already knew you cover
and defend the end zone so it's not like
this is going to revolutionize anything
this is like
the miracle in the meadowlands happening
now this is the equivalent of the
attempted handoff instead of victory
formation that's what this is
no question mike and that that's
probably the best example of of a dumb
play call that ended up costing a team a
game and we all remember that one but
you're right this isn't going to change
anything
teams know how to defend when there are
seconds left in a game and the other
team has no timeouts and they're at
midfield and they're in need of a
touchdown i mean it's simple it's it's
it's not that hard to do unless you get
beat on a hail mary something like the
bills got beat on uh with deandre
hopkins making just a great play but at
least they had it defended they got beat
on that but they had it defended you
know how to defend the raiders in this
situation and you fail to do it but mike
also adam gase i think is getting off
too easy on this you know i think he
bears some responsibility he is the head
coach he can overrule the defensive
coordinator
the play caller if it's him or whoever
it is he can he can overrule that he
ultimately is in charge of this team and
he said he wishes now that he had called
timeout or overruled in that situation
he didn't but he does bear blame for for
letting that play play out as it did
this is one of the problems
of a coach who is an expert in one side
of the ball delegating half
of the game at least as it relates to
the play from scrimmage not special
teams but half of the game gets
completely and totally not not delegated
but abdicated to another coach we see
mike zimmer do it in minnesota with his
offensive guy we see offensive coaches
do it with their defensive coordinator
when you have structured this as
you're basically the head coach of the
defense
the the pieces aren't there the
foundation isn't there
to intervene
when something stupid like this is about
to happen it's trying to stretch one of
those brand new big rubber bands that
has never been stretched before you've
never done it it's not what you do so in
that moment all of a sudden you're like
wait holy crap the guy that i've given
the keys to the car to is about to drive
the car off the cliff what do i do
well what what can you do if you've
never stopped him before from dropping
it into a tree or driving it off the
road or driving it anywhere it's an
awkward spot you haven't created a
system where you've got that ability to
say time out what the hell are you
thinking and uh you know i think in that
moment and you're in the crucible and
everything's happening fast and you
figure what the hell let's go see let's
see what happens uh maybe we'll get
lucky here i just think it's a lot in
real time in the moment to harness and
and it and it's a product of
creating a situation
where you delegate and abdicate so much
responsibility of the team to one person
and if we've learned one thing about
greg williams over the years he's the
last person you want to abdicate
responsibility for half of your team too
so that's why it blew up in adam gase's
face let's hear from adam gase earlier
today talking about the decision to
politely ask greg williams to get the
hell out of here
did you agree with his decision last
night on
the blitz call at the end of the game
and how much factored into that call
factored into your decision
well i
obviously wasn't happy about that call
um
and
you know that
that was a
heartbreaking way for our guys to to
lose a game
you know
for
for that to happen in that situation
it's just
just
we can't have that happen
that was such a long pause bill
belichick said man that's a long pause
from adam gase but look it's it's all
it's all crumbling and if he wants
to escape the fate that befell rod
marinelli in 2008
hugh jackson in 2017 you got to get
williams out of there you've got to
because william's name
doesn't go on the owen 16 trophy gases
name does and here's the best example of
that shireen
i had to go back and refresh my memory
on whether or not greg williams was the
defensive coordinator of the 2017 browns
i thought there's no way there's no way
i'd remember that right no you think
winless head coach winless head coach
not coordinators not anybody but head
coach and greg williams and and i think
at some level the argument for keeping
him is you're staying here with me
you're going down i'm going down with
the ship
and you're going down with the ship too
you're not getting out of it this easy
greg you're going to have 2-0 and 16s
they may not remember one they're going
to remember too
and i think they remember greg williams
now mike he has sealed his fate with
that for sure i found an interesting
stat espn had this stat i thought it was
very interesting there have been
252 plays in a similar situation
as they as the jets had on sunday
over the last 15 years and this was the
only time that a defensive coordinator
six sent six or more pass rushers i just
thought it was a fantastic uh stat and
it just shows you
how bad that play call was that the fact
that no other defensive coordinator has
done that in the history of the game and
this is a guy mike when you look at his
22 years career as a defensive
coordinator a head coach overseeing the
defense only four times have they
finished in the top
ten in top five and yards allowed only
three times in points loud it's not like
he's a great defensive coordinator so
stop giving him jobs he can't get the
job done go find somebody else to coach
your defense and the jets now have done
that but it's going to be way too late
for adam gase and this staff they will
be gone at season's end the good thing
for jets fans though mike they retain
the number one overall draft pick and
they're going to have a new coaching
staff and maybe some new hope after this
year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports